Speaker 1: . And finally today, speaking of
victories, if you can kind of call it that,
the Dallas Independent School
District has announced that
even though the Texas Supreme Court
ruled over the weekend that they cannot.
Overrun the governors ban en masse mandates they
have announced that we're still going to require
people to wear masks, we're leaving our masks
mandate in place. Texas Supreme Court, what are
you going to do about it? We're going to protect
these kids. We are going to do everything possible
to try to slow the spread or heck, even prevent
the spread of covid in our school district.
And so I applaud the Dallas Independent
School District for doing this,
and if you're not familiar with the Supreme Court
case in the state of Texas, Texas Supreme Court,
over the weekend, the Texas Supreme Court ruled
that the areas of Texas that had basically ignored
Republican Governor Greg Abbott's ban on
mask mandates, Supreme Court said, hey,
you can't do that. He has the authority under the
Texas Emergency Act of nineteen seventy five. He
has the authority to do this because those are
his emergency powers and corvids. An emergency.
And to me, it's OK if it's an emergency. Why
aren't we doing everything possible to protect
people? And I think, honestly, that if the
lawyers had probably had better arguments
and probably weren't going in front of one
of the most right wing courts in the country,
this easily would have been a victory for the
districts. But Texas Supreme Court clearly
packed with Republicans. So, yes, of course,
they're going to roll with whatever Abbott wants
them to say. But again, it should have been
very easy in a fair district to be able to,
as the plaintiffs point out, that the governor's
decision was not based on any health data
or scientific data. It was based on partizan
politics and therefore should not be protected
under that 1975 Texas Emergency Act or any other
district or state or court. You're going to win
this. And we actually know that because
they already won it in the lower court.
But the Texas Supreme Court said it's not going
to fly. But at least the school district is saying
I'm a stand up to this, these kids are going
to school wearing masks. This is what it is.
What are you going to do? You're going to
punish us for it, punish us, but we're going
to protect these kids. And I applaud them for
that, as I mentioned earlier in the program.
An eighth grader in Mississippi died of covid
last week. Four hundred and forty students and
faculty members in Broward County, Florida,
I believe it was Broward on quarantine
for teachers in Broward County, dead from
covid last week within 24 hours of one another.
Covid outbreaks have shut down five
school districts in the state of Georgia
in the last week. Five districts
shut down because of covid outbreaks.
And I have no doubt that the Dallas Independent
School District is looking around them
and saying we have to do something, we can't allow
ourselves to become what these other Republican
controlled states are becoming. And if we have
to defy a court order to protect these kids,
then by God, we're going to defy a
court order to protect these kids.
So kudos and bravo to the Dallas Independent
School District for standing up for the safety
of these children. Thank you very much for tuning
in today. Thank you to David Pakman, you know,
this weekend, last week, allowing me the time to
come on, serve as your fill in host. Thanks to
everyone at the staff of The David Pakman Show.
Patrick, you've been wonderful to work with here.
And if you want more from me, YouTube, dotcom,
fair and balanced, YouTube dotcom slash the ring
of fire, Twitter, Facebook
and Instagram at Fair and
Balanced wonderful bonus show.
Coming up today from members.
I'm Ferron Cousins. Thank you for watching
Unidentified: The David Pakman Show.